Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome to The Flame in the Flood.
Now this is a game that Amy has been requesting
that I play for quite some time now
and I won't be putting it off any longer
and to be perfectly honest here, it opened up on quite a sad scene
because I noticed that this dog is hanging around this skeleton here.
Was that its owner?
And the owner died?
And now the dog is just not leaving the bones alone.
That's like incredibly sad.
It's like barking at the bones.
Oh no! My heart is breaking right now.
Okay so this game is um-
Oh.
*reads* Recommended for new players
Checkpoints, normal abundance of supplies
Recommended for experienced players
Permadeath, fewer supplies, stats diminish at an increased rate
Well... You know...
Lets go in this with both eyes open as a traveler
because I'm not gonna be-
I'm not going to assume I know anything about this game and-
Oh!
Oh okay!
Was that not the owner and you were just scavenging?
Were you just going to make sure that skellington wasn't going to attack you?
Please tell me that's not the case
'cause that's always so sad
Oh!
Hello, pup!
Pup, are you a sweet pup?
Oh, where are you going with that?
Oh, hi.
Hello! Is that me?
Hi!
Okay good!
Maybe good?
Oh no! It was the old owner.
and now you found a new owner.
I think.
Ah! So sad.
Maybe .
I don't know *laughs*
*dog barks*
Okay... *dog barks*
So I know nothing about the backstory of this game.
So I'm kinda going into it completely blind.
I've seen maybe a trailer for it.
and-
Ooh- point or click
Yeah okay- ooh!
Hello!
*reads* Traveled zero miles.
Well, good to know I've made absolutely no progress in my life.
Let's pick some corn.
I've got some time I suppose.
*reads* Ash cake schematic added to journal.
Why would I wanna make an ash cake?
How do I make an ash cake?
Get charcoal?
Did I just stick my hand in that fire?
What kind of badass am I?
Okay so I think the point of this is that we need to keep moving here.
*reads* Scout Basics
Open Scout's backpack to access items, craft supplies and examine your condition.
Keep an eye on Scout's health.
Hunger, thirst, temperature, and rest
Oh, I am getting a lot of don't starve vibes about this
and I have a funny feeling that I am going to be starving rather quickly here.
Good thing I didn't do survivalist
because holy shit.
This is more in depth than I thought it was going to be.
Aw! Does the poochie have a name?
Does the poochie have a name?
*reads* swipe and shoo crows
SHOO! GET OUT OF HERE!
I DON'T LIKE YOU!
I don't like your kind around here.
Alright. Search through here I guess.
Ah! Water filter, splint, jar.
Okay. So I can freely break my leg at my leisure
and I don't have to worry about that.
Examine.
*reads* Cleaned this pace out long ago. Nothing left but dust.
Ah! Good there's a squirrel with big boobs.
Oh. No wait. Is that a collar?
I have no idea.
I probably shouldn't have said that.
Oh well.
I've gotten myself in trouble already in the beginning of this.
Let's play.
But carrying on.
What are you barking at, boy?
Whatcha barking at?
What's going on?
What do you see there?
Wh-Whatcha doing?
SHOO!
Come this way.
Why do you keep barking?
There can't be anything over there.
Are you Scout or am I Scout?
Imma call you Wimbly.
*reads* Caches
"No one is useless in this world who lightens the burdens of another."
Caches contain notes with tasks to help you survive.
Complete tasks and find helpful supplies as a reward.
Okay!
Get task.
*reads* Basic tools.
Ooh!
I dunno what I need to do about that.
Oooh!
I dunno what this is, but let's do it.
I'm all about moving forward into the unknown.
Oh geez. Maybe I shouldn't have done this.
Maybe I wasn't prepared at all.
*music starts playing*
Here we go then I guess.
I guess we're going on an amazing adventure!
and I didn't even know how to make it-
Why- I don't know what I'm doing
I'm gonna paddle this way.
*grunts*
Okay.
Huh.
Paddle hard and steer.
Oh.
*Intense Music*
AHH!
*Intense music continues*
Frick dude.
Boost.
Okay. Oh, boy.
Oh, boy.
Alright, I'm trying to navigate through it without dying.
Okay. So, that's another thing that I don't know.
Ooh! Red eyes in the darkness.
That's probably not good.
Ugh.
Okay.
Is that just-
The music is awesome in this game.
I gotta admit.
But I still don't know much about the story of this game.
I mean, just assuming by the name of it
"The Flame in the Flood"
I'm assuming that they're- OW!
Dog! Are you okay?
I'm sorry about that.
I'm assuming there must have been a flood of some sort
that just came through absolutely everything.
and maybe a majority of the world is under water and is just being washed away.
Ahh! Oh my goodness!
Sorry Poochie!
I'm sorry.
Oh boy. Oh wow. It is hard to steer.
*grunts*
Wait. What is that?
Wait. Okay, I got nuts and bolts. Great!
I got a bunch of nuts and bolts.
Oh look! A house boat!
It's so cool!
I love the stylistic nature of it.
I like any game that has a style to it.
But I like it when the style works really well.
It really works well here.
I like it a lot.
What is that?
I don't know.
Is that a fishing village?
Can I go over there?
Can I trade something?
I've got nuts AND bolts.
and some cattails.
and also maybe a corn
I could cook them up an ash cake if they'd like that.
Ow!
Sorry.
Okay, what is this?
Oh! I can break!
If I hit the backwards key, I can break.
Alright, Imma dock here.
I don't know what the hell.
Entering Tyland.
Also known as Tyler the Apocalypse Sheid Dominion.
He went crazy and used his eagle scout knowledge
to command an entire sector of the forest.
I just gotta hope he's still got his senses with him.
I hope he's still smiling always.
'Cause if he's not
Oh, if he's not
Oh, don't mind if I take all of your shit.
*whispers* Sorry Tyler.
I'm so sorry.
Can I search that?
There we go.
Alright. *music stops*
Who's here in the Bait Shack?
Now that the music is cut out, I just have the soothing sounds of my own voice
Loot?
Alright, I'll take it.
I guess everyone here is dead.
That's kind of depressing.
Huh.
Yeah. I-I don't know. I've never even thought about it.
Is everyone here dead or-- ?
How many people are-
How many people are left alive in this world?
and why do I need to run so far?
That makes me think that maybe
just maybe if i could skedaddle here
Ooh! Hey! Aahh! NO!
Okay. We're fine.
Everything's fine. Don't worry about it.
I know you're scared about something.
Okay. We're fine.
I don't know what this is all about.
Oooh!
What is you?
It's cool.
So I may or may not be mistaken about
this but I believe that this game is kind of
procedurally generated.
I may be completely wrong about that
but it's kind of like
how long can you survive
going into the wilderness
and surviving?
But then again, I have no idea.
That's only my guess right now.
I could be completely wrong about that.
This could be actually like a story.
*reads* corn fed
Corn fed me?
Am I gonna feed corn to my doggy?
What am I gonna do?
How do I do that?
What do I even do about those objectives?
They don't give me a lot of details.
Oh!
Uh!
Ah!
Okay!
So I need to craft a stone knife and a stone hammer.
Then collect ten corn.
I can do that.
I don't know where I'm gonna get corn.
If there's a corn farm around here any place, I could probably
steal from them.
Kill the owners.
Take all of their supplies.
*mumbles* Then I'd be very happy about my life.
*reads* Craft a pouch to expand your inventory.
Okay. Where's the crafting menu?
Okay. Here we go.
Afflictions. None.
Doing great.
*reads* Braided cord, stitching, tinder, ash cake
Huh. I can't make shit.
That's a lot of stuff to make.
I am not even close to doing any of that.
How do you expect me to do this if I don't even know what I am up against?
But I do need flint.
Then eventually I'm going to need a stone ax.
But I don't have either of the supplies to do that.
So I have to...
*hissing noise*
What the fuck was that?
You wanna run that by me again?
What the hell was that?
*dog barks*
I don't even know.
Okay. So, it says I have to make
I had- I had to make like a patch or a pocket to be able to make more
Ooh! Here we go!
*reads* Aesop's Bag
Oh, Aesop!
Oh! My dog Aesop!
His name is Aesop!
Aw, that's cool.
That's adorable.
Okay, so I don't have the schematics to be able to build all that stuff
What are you-
Where are you going?
Are you leading me somewhere?
Cause I'm following you. *Aesop barks*
What? What?
Aesop what is it?
Dig?
Dig, boy.
Dig.
I don't have a shovel.
I just don't
Okay let's get out of here.
Let's skedaddle.
Let's go!
Let's move!
Move!
So, hopefully we're gonna find something a bit more substantial in the next one.
But this is cool. Just like the ideas behind it.
I like this.
*singing* Skiddly doo
Skaddladly doo
*singing* Oh boy. It's night. That's no good.
*Stopped singing* Ew, what is that?
Ew, what is that?
Oh, it's a tree. Okay, never mind.
It was a tree everybody. Don't worry about it. It was a tree.
A big ol' tree. Oh boy. Oh, whew.
Why is the night full of terrors?
Why are we in Game of Thrones country?
Why are you all staring at me like that?
So, I am beginning to think it may be a bad idea to go uh...
dock in the middle of the night.
'Cause whew. That don't look good.
That looks like something I may be able to upgrade my good ol' raft to.
Maybe. Maybe. And also some sort of camping ground over there.
But I'm gonna try this one first because maybe I'm gonna get another schematic
or maybe meet another living human because that would be kind of nice
but then again maybe I shouldn't dock in the middle of the night.
*singing* I'm gonna risk it. I'm gonna risk it and dock.
Hello?
Man, where did all that epic music go?
I was ready for it.
*reads* Use the marina
Oh!
I can make minor repairs!
That's literally all I can do!
I can't do anything except repair the damage I have done.
But I did something so that's kind of cool.
Okay.
So there's a lot of potential in the future of this.
Like beyond the very beginning of it obviously.
You're gonna learn more and more about the game
It seems to be a lot more complex than I though it was.
Which is interesting.
So.. so also the other thing I  gotta do is
I have to transfer stuff over to my boat and I'll do that the next time I find a way to dock.
Skadoosh
Skabloosh
Get going
Get gone.
Come on. Yeehaw.
Oh! Navigate.
Alright. There we go.
Oh. What is that?
Well, there might be corn there, but there also might be death there in the form of wolves.
I got a bad feeling about that.
Light on supplies in the wilderness.
Let me transfer some stuff over.
If I can my uh
raft
There we go.
*reading* raft, raft, raft, RA- *coughing*
No, I don't need to do that.
What did I just use? I have no idea.
*reading* raft and raft
Okay that should be good.
Alright, here we go.
LETS DO THIS!
I dunno what we're gonna get but hopefully it's something good.
Can I jump up there? No, I can't.
SHOO! Alright.
Sapling.
Mmm.
Looks spooky in here.
Oh, hello.
Is that a crow?
Hey! A flint. I can make a knife.
Get out of here.
Oh, what's this?
I can sleep here in this abandoned bus in the middle of nowhere.
Mulberries. I'll take that.
Insulated pants.
That's gonna be good.
Hello
Yes thank you.
I'll sleep there in a second maybe.
Just as soon as I find out if this is all good.
*grunting*
Uh.. fill jar?
No jars to fill?
I thought I had a jar!
Dammit.
Alright, I'll drink it then.
Glug
Okay, good.
Mul-*gasp* Oh! Hey! Oh! Woah! Woah! Woah!
SHOO!
WOAH!
Good golly.
I can't fight you.
I don't know how to fight.
Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh! I'm gonna sleep in here!
I'm gonna sleep!
Sleep!
Okay! Alright, don't mind me I'm just sleeping.
Oh geez, that's not good.
I might- Oh geez I'm wet. Blah.
Also, I've been hit?
When did I get hit?
When the hell did I get hit?
I dodged that bore like a boss.
All right. Fine. I'm gonna craft me up...
Some insulated this stuff maybe.
I dunno.
Can I make a stone knife?
I need a braided cord.
Okay.
Braided Cord
Okay, I got those.
I'm gonna make a stone knife so at least I can fight.
And then I think I need to make tinder.
Oh box trap!
Cool!
Oh snare.
That sounds like it might be useful.
I don't have any use for it though.
I've got some other stuff though.
I've got mulberries.
I don't know if those are going to be good but
I'll consume all of those.
Just shove them all inside of me.
That's good stuff.
Good stuff right there.
All right, so now that I've got a stone knife
Oh where am I going?
Can I- I am not controlling myself.
Why was I just running off there?
Alright whatever.
It's fine.
Oh God dammit that bore.
Yeesh.
No no no no no no no
Okay missed me!
How do I-
God dammit. I had it.
Didn't I?
It was on my tool belt.
It's right there!
How do I get that out?
Guess I can eat some corn.
Th-That's good.
All right.
I ju- I- Imma keep eating corn.
'Cause I have nothing else to do with my time.
I better try to make a fire somehow.
I got tinder.
How do I make a fire?
Is that even possible?
*reads* campfire
*reads* old lumber, flint, dry tinder
I've got none of those.
I should get off of this death hole called an island.
I should just get the fudge out of here.
I imagine
that in a game called The Flame in the Flood
it probably rains a lot
so I need to keep moving and find better supplies
than whats in the sparse wilderness here.
Alright. Oh, I don't know what that was all-
Oh no! That's what had the nuts and bolts!
*music starts playing*
Oh!
It's so nice!
It's a new day!
Oh I love it!
Oh It's so good!
Oh that's nice!
Oh!
I'm a traveler.
I'm an explorer.
I'm also a survivor.
I don't know what exactly ended the world except for
*crash*
Well all right then.
Oh! I'm trying not to!
It's actually much harder than you think it would be.
Penicillin?
Oh good!
That's a good schematic to have.
Oh It's so nice.
Oh it's so nice.
Ahh! *crash*
God dammit!
Imma blow up my raft here.
Okay, so it's a combination of trying to
steer, slow down, and also boost yourself
out of the way of obstacles.
It's got to be like uh
an all three thing or you're not gonna get anywhere
Here we go.
All right. What is this?
Campground.
That might have some goodies.
*reads* often has flint. Always has lit fire.
Oh! That's so handy!
Oh, that's so nice.
Oh, it's so nice
I'll take that.
Use fire.
Oh, so nice.
Oh much better than the bores.
Oh good stuff.
Okay. I'm out of space for now.
But I can transfer some stuff to Aesop.
Aesop come here boy.
Oh penicillin. Okay. That's good.
Uh... Aesop can carry that.
Aesop can also carry this.
and that.
and um
this.
and that. Okay!
So that will be enough for Aesop.
Alright so
Oh man, is this game just like full of uh...
Ah man, why can't I think of the type of music that this is?
Uh... It's not country obviously.
It's not bluegrass or anything like that. What's it called?
Ah! You know the mumford and  sons bullshit going on there.
You know what I'm talking about.
You know what I got going on.
That type of music.
That's always- That's always nice.
It's so cool.
This game has personality which I can always appreciate.
All right what have we got.
*reads* stop bleeding
Oh okay. Is that the only thing I have to do?
Alright well.
Stop bleeding?
Might as well ask me to stop breathing.
*reads* cure a laceration. You can bandage it and stitch it up.
Okay. So I need a leather kit for that.
Alrighty then. I can figure something out.
Devils trumpet?
Hell yeah. That's what they used to call me in highschool.
I can craft up a snare can't I?
Yeah I can.
So if I take the snare
and I...
I don't need to make a campfire cause I already got one.
So I made a snare
So if I
deploy the snare like right about there
then when the rabbits come out in the morning
I should have a tasty treat that can't be beat
and then I'll be slightly sad about it but at least I'll not be starving.
which I currently am
and then if i just go to bed
here
I can sleep until
I can sleep for 8 hours.
I'll be starving
I'll have no food which is
bad but
maybe I'll have a rabbit.
Ooh thats no good
I'm riding the train of all the fires in this entire area
Rabbit!
Rabbit?
Rabbit! I've got a rabbit!
I've got a rabbit!
Skinned rabbit, skinabbit!
Oh dead rabbit. Alright then
spoils after four days.
Lets skin that rabbit dead.
Ah
Don't have inventory space.
Aesop you want a deviled trumpets.
Can be fatal if ingested.
A good fixin' if you mean to kill a critter.
why would you kill it with that poison and then try to eat it?
thats thats no good
O i can eat this
Why not uhh maybe i can make myself some good old rabbit stew if I do that
Alright Aesop you
You want to hold on to some stuff for me you want to hold on to this salt
Ima skin this
Ima skin that rabbit here we go I'm gonna skin it
Mmmmm
Yay I can make jerky
Ooo actually thats good, tainted meat? Again...
Why would I want to do that don't eat it it will kill you maybe if I want to kill a wolllllllf
Ahhh that could be good
I can make a rabbit pelt hat!
Oooo
I like...literally all of this
All of this is great. So now i just need to cook me up a rabat